그 자리에서 안정적으로 오래 영업을
하실 분들은 당연히 매입을 하시는게
좋을 거 같고요네데 매입을 하실 때
개인으로도 매입할 수 있지만 범인으로
매입이 좋은
이유는 법인으로 메이비 좋은 이유는
대출 측면이라고 봤어요 지금 뭐
그렇다고 대출 많이 받는게 무조건
좋은 건 아니겠지만 장사를 한다라는
거는 경우에는 시간과 돈을 맞바꾸는
개념이라고 저 생각해요 어쨌든 우리는
장사를 하는 이유가 짧은 시간 안에
빨리 돈을 벌어서 또 다음 사업을
준비하는 부분도 꽤
크거든요이 자리에서 어차피 시간
지나면 월세도 계속 올라갈 거고
나중에 뭐 또 사업장을 옮겨야 되면
또 인테리어 비용부터 해서 돈이
나중에 어차피 나갈 거라면 법인
투자를 통해서라도 건물을 매입하면
추가적으로 나갈 것들을 안 나가겠다
할 수 있다라는 점이 정말 좋은
점이고 사업은 어쨌든 향후에 또 다음
아이템 또 다음 사업들을 계속
계획해야 되다 보니까 그럴 만한
안정적인 공간이 있을 때 훨씬 더
사업을 추진하기에는 좋다라는 생각이
좀 들었어요 지금도 실은 요식업
경기가 좋지는 않거든요 좋지는 않아서
매출이 막 조금 지금 출렁출렁 하지만
그래도 저희는 월세가 어쨌든 부담은
없으니까 남들이 이럴 때 음식값 올릴
때 저희는 음식값을 안 올렸어요
음식값을 안 올리고 갈 수 있는게
우리는 어쨌든 임대로 가 안 나가니까
인건비 정도만 서로 조율하면 되니까
그렇게 해서 고객 분들한테 더
돌려드릴 수 있는 부분도 있고 그런게
쌓일 때 음식점이 저는 오래 간다라고
봤어요 그 사업이 순간적으로 잘되는
것도 중요하지만 언제 안 될지
모르잖아요 그래서 얘를 안정적으로
오래할 수 있게 만드는 것 중에
하나는 내 건물에 사는 것만큼 좋은
거 없는 거 같습니다 연도가 어느
정도 되죠 지금 저희 건물이 89년도
건물이 이니까 거의 뭐 30년이
넘었죠 30년이 넘어서 쫑 종씩 고칠
부분은 분명히 있는 건물이긴 하죠 아
그래서 앞으로 뭐 이렇게 리모델링할
계획도 있으신 거 같 어네 계획도
갖고 있습니다 일단은 저의 사업에
맞게 뭔가 내부적인 거를 좀 손볼
생각이고요 그때 손 보면서 제가 그때
빌사남 스터디에서도 많이 배웠던
부분이지만 건물은 결국에는 외관이
정말 정말 중요하잖아요 외관 중요하고
엘리베이터의 유모가 중요하고 저희
건물은 지금 엘리베이터가 없어요 음
네베 있을 그 금 검는 중 외관 지금
저가 드라이비트로 되어 있는 건물이다
보니까 비올 때 별로 좋지가 않아서
그런 부분을 감안할 수 있는 마감제
형태로 좀 바꿀 생각이요 사실 그
건물 외관을 사실 얼굴이라 그요 저
사실 얼굴만 잘 바꿔도 돼요 나중에
좀 이렇게 바뀌고 나서 또 한번 좀
이렇게 보면은 좋을 것 같습니다
다음에 이제 리모델링 되고 나서
그때는 매장에 가서 찍으면 좋을 것
같아요 아 저희 너무 좋습니다 너무
좋습니다 델링 된 것도 한번 좀
소개해 주시고 네네 음식도 소개해
드리고 그죠 아 그리고 지금 연남동
매장이 있으시죠네 저희가 실제로는
지금 신촌 현대 백카 전면 리틀
쿠바라는 브랜드도 하고 있고요
그다음에 연남동에 이제 더 스테이크
주벤 쿠바라는 브랜드 하고 있고 또
연남동 안쪽에 이제 오로라 케이크
하우스라는 곳도 저희가 지금 하고
있어요 아 지금 그럼 총 몇 개 매자
지금네 개하고 있습니다 이번을 계기로
매장 늘릴 때마다 그 건물들을 살 수
있게 아 꼭 원하고 있습니다 실은
지금 제가 카페 비즈니스를 이제
도전해 보고 있는 이유가 바로이
이유기 해요 아 그니까 저희가 양식을
하고 있거든요네 어떤 건물이 하나
있다고 쳤을 때 그 건물에 1 2
3층이 전부 다 양식이면
이상하잖아요 근데 양식을 드시고
연계될 수 있는 서비스로 따졌을 때는
저는 카페만 한게 없 없다고
생각했어요 아 그죠 그래서 지금 저희
제가 사업을 매입할 때도 저희 2층에
지금 카페가 있어요 실제로도 요렇게
조화롭게 건물의 가치를 상승시킬 수
있는 부분이니까 또한 그 컨텐츠를
제가 직접 소화해서 직접 운영할 수
있으면 사업을 통해서도 이윤을 남길
수 있고 부동산을 통해서도 이윤을
남길 수 있고 지금처럼 지하에가
식자제 공간을 만들어서 유통에서도
마은에 남길 수 있으면 어쨌든 장사를
해보신 분들은 느끼시겠지만
장만으로 돈 버는게 생각보다 아주
어렵거든요 아까 말씀하신 대로 기복도
있고 될 땐 또 잘 됐다가 안 될
때는 벌어 돈돈 까먹으면서 버티고
그렇기 때문에 말씀 주신 부동산적
가치도 꾸준히 끌고 가고 부가적인
거를 무조건 창출해야 된다고
생각합니다 그냥 일반적인 투자자분들은
그렇게 하기 어렵잖아요 뭐 안에
컨텐츠도 넣기도 어렵고 아니면 그냥
이제 임대를 맞춰야 되는데 그러기가
요즘에 좀 쉽지 않으니까 제가 봤을
때 대표님처럼 이렇게 좀 컨텐츠
있으시고 또 이제 자기 사업 이렇게
공간을 잘하고 계신 분들은 좀 빌딩을
매입하는 것도 한번 생각해 보면 좋을
거 같 어 너무 좋은 거 같습니다
저는 너무 강력 추천드립니다 아 아
나도 내 건물에서 사업을 해야 지금
내가 생각하는 것들을 할 수 있을 것
같은데 27기 있나요 제가 28기
있나요 부동산 스터디에 그래서 제가
참여를 했던 거거든요 bsn 분들을
저희한테 매칭을 해 주시잖아요 매칭을
해 주셔서 같이 임장도 많이 다니고
그러 면서도 저 한편으로는 제가
장사하고 있는 건물에 대한 매입
가능성도 그때 여쭤 보던 건데 렇게
이렇게 잘 풀어 주셔서 제가 오히려
감사하게 잘
했습니다 말씀 너무 잘 드렸고 그
앞으로 혹시 또 계획은 어떻게 되세요
또 이제 저희는 성수동 쪽도 많이
관심 갖고 있어서 성수동에서 저희
브랜드 할 수 있게 이렇게 열심히
펼쳐 보려고 합니다 거기에도 뭐 좋은
뭐 임대인분 계시면 네 같이할 수도
있으니까요 아마이 영상 보시는 분들
중에 아마 건물주 분들도 좀 많이
계신데 혹시 만약에 관심 있으시다고
하면 주바 찾아보시면 됩 그래서 한번
검색해서 한번 보시고 한번 가서
식사도 한번 해보시고 기회 된다라고
하면은 같이 이렇게 뭐 조인해서
하셔도 예 너무 좋을 것 같고요 아
그런면 너무 감사하죠 어 저희
마지막으로 저 빌사 TV 구독자
분들한테 좀 혹시 하실 말씀
있으실까요 저도 이예 김윤수 대표님
덕분에 이렇게 건물 배입 이게 어떻게
보면은 저의 작은 꿈을 하나 이루게
된 건데 꼭 도전하시고 희망하시는
일들 다 잘 이루시는 24년 되셨으면
좋겠습니다네 그래서 혹시 나중에 이제
매장을 찾으실 때 한번 저희 비사
TV 구독자분들은 보고 왔다고 해
주시면은 어 저희가 그러면 서비스 예
저희가 무조건 음료가 됐던 뭐가 됐던
무조건 다 챙겨 드리겠습니다 그래서
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다
감사합니다
감사합니다네